marvel's guardians of the galaxy puts
you in the hover boots of star-lord and
asks you to lead a team of the galaxy's
deadliest heroes you might not get to
control the rest of the guardians
directly but don't be fooled you have to
work as a team in order to make the most
of the game's combat the game loves to
throw all sorts of different terms
attack properties and status effects at
you and while i don't think this is a
particularly difficult game it did take
me a lot longer than i thought it would
to really get the full hang of the
combat which is why i'm here to lay it
all down for you so you'll have more of
a leg up than i did when you start the
game and if you find this helpful please
give a like and sub it helps out a
lot smooth plan so far
hey at least i'm pulling my weight
there's not much weight to pull yes
star-lord may have guns to pupe you with
but it's important to understand that
while they deal damage and are perfectly
capable of taking down lower tier
enemies the real focus is on the
abilities both peters and the rest of
the guardians abilities can do all sorts
of stuff like crowd control multi or
single enemy damage but a key element to
focus on is if it's a damage ability or
a stagger ability damage is exactly what
it sounds like focusing on taking out
large chunks of the enemy's health bar
gamora's starting ability deadly strike
deals heavy damage to a single target
making her your best damage dealer early
in the game however some enemies might
be resistant to gamora's attacks certain
higher tier foes will have a stagger bar
and if you want to take them down
effectively you'll need to fill it using
abilities that cause stagger once full
the enemy will become
staggered which leaves them vulnerable
to previously resisted abilities drax's
starting move destroy deals heavy
stagger so a basic combo would be to use
drax to stagger someone and then have
gamora sweep in with heavy damage
so the key is going to be spending time
learning the role each move serves you
can find all of this information on the
abilities menu memorizing each move
sounds like a lot to handle but each
character only gets 4 moves total
throughout the game and you unlock them
at a slow enough pace so you don't get
overwhelmed also a handy little combat
tip if you forget which move causes
stagger when you pull up the ability
menu in combat stacker moves will always
have the stagger icon on them another
thing you have to consider is elemental
moves over the course of the game peter
gets access to elemental shots on his
blasters these moves are used both in
puzzles as well as combat sometimes the
uses will be pretty obvious like
destroying these enemy shields with your
eye shot but in the heat of battle you
might not be sure how best to use your
elemental attacks thankfully the game
actually makes this pretty easy to the
left of the enemy's health bar is a
square box with an icon which tells you
which type of shot is best effective
standard enemies will have this blaster
icon which means peter's basic attack
works best while special foes will have
icons associated with different elements
now this might all sound really obvious
but the game doesn't explain this and it
actually took me longer than i'd like to
admit to notice this so consider this me
passing these savings on to you
a seemingly minor but important move you
might actually forget about is that
peter has a melee attack typically you
aren't going to be using this all that
much you're better off blasting or using
an ability and you're gonna kind of
forget it's a thing but melee can
actually be pretty effective especially
when peter happens to combo a melee with
other guardians to do more damage and
there are some enemies that are weak to
melee and you can make really short work
of them unfortunately there really isn't
any sort of tell i could find and you
just need to experiment to see which
enemies are weak to melee just give them
a good whack and you'll know right away
if the melee is effective or not okay so
now that you know how to use all your
tools it's time to maximize your damage
certain abilities can apply a damage
multiplier to the enemy as signified by
this icon here
each guardian is capable of applying
their own multiplier meaning you can
stack them on a single enemy up to five
times however getting it this high is
pretty tricky the effect doesn't stay
very long so you'll need to blow all of
your abilities at the same time which
might not even be the best idea for
reasons we'll talk about plus on common
foes you'll likely kill them before
getting all the way to a stack of 5.
i recommend only trying to get higher
stacks on larger boss enemies and for
common encounters focus on just getting
two stacks instead and then lay down the
damage interestingly the game doesn't
communicate to you which abilities apply
a damage multiplier leading to a bit of
guesswork for me it always triggered on
abilities that affect multiple targets
like peter's eye of the hurricane
gamora's shadow strike drax's pound and
pummel rocket's grav stick grenade and
groot entangle when you're juggling all
these different systems stagger
elemental damage multipliers not only
does it dish out the hurt but it also
increases your momentum meter this is
basically the game's way of saying hey
you're doing a good job keep it up aside
from a nice pat on the back the reason
you care about momentum is because
raising it higher will increase your
chances of bonus attack prompts
triggering giving you free damage you'll
also gain a larger xp payout at the end
of a fight momentum will decrease while
being inactive so you want to be laying
down the hurt constantly but repeating
the same moves over and over reduces how
much momentum they give you so you want
to keep mixing up your tactics the worst
thing you can do is spam all 5 guardian
abilities in one go instead try and pace
them out to keep your momentum up this
all sounds like a lot to keep track of
but the good thing is the game layers a
lot of these systems slowly over time
practice each new element as it's
introduced and soon you'll be kicking
ass as a well-coordinated team i'm going
to leave you with some gameplay of
everything i just talked about all
coming together so you can see in action
and remember if you found this video
helpful please why not give a like and
sub it really helps us out and make sure
to stay tuned to gamespot for our full
review of marvel's guardians of the
galaxy
drags
[ __ ] fireworks
oh sucker suck on this yeah hello
time's up
keep them busy crew
okay coast is clear you're up rocket
make it fast of course there ain't a
lock this side of zandar i can't [ __ ] i
am adding to your debt for every extra
minute this takes keep your mannies on
you can't rush genius